ah
it works
Hi first time here on hand not only for
children but the first games of
law, personal message also comes
Good night to everyone, everyone is starting.
to convey that android developer
relations brazil that directly
google's office in sao paulo
this time our legal effects
sound that I'm using for the first time.
I'm having fun then I'll have it
that I put up with it, I'm trying and
alternative time to see if it is
more convenient for people because
there were many comments that on 7
seven at night how are you doing before
A lot of people are in transit but a lot
people are stuck on the marginal
Other girls from São Paulo stay like this
ends up not being able to participate
renault
so I'm trying experimentally
make a late check-in right?
It's a good thing, it's cool, I just
arrive at the office countries that hit
A few odd hours there.
You look at the clock. Mourning says I confused.
to mpm again then it's always good
Let's start, then we have some.
questions of what have been done so
and I want to talk about a
novelty that appeared recently in the
duel against andrade dotcom that is well
cool for those who are developing
and who are and are looking for
a series of criteria to protest
Ram application quality is clear
I tried our design guide that
through which you can know if you
is following the new design pattern of the
android but what was missing was
a series of tests in a series of
items for you to check
publishing the application is for you to have
sure that you are all with the
quality goal
obviously this lesson of the image is not only
follow all the items that magically
you will have a good app but she
It sure serves as a guide lets me
see if you can share my screen
Here to show you where it is.
This has worked out, you should be seeing
here a developers 12 point screen with
so here is the website when you arrive
click Distributed
this last item went to
record and then this is a new function
who just talks about some points
important in relation to the quality of
applications
is then tech 3 subsections one of them calls
corep collor and what are the gas lines
for the quality of the applications is
general terms, ie any type of
application is established by
while type then it has since design
visual interaction with the user it passes
for various things like for example
by functionality and goes through
stability performance
each and every one of the sessions
have a series of tests in which
small phrases are tests that
you can do to determine if the
application is following the
criterion then especially if you are
developer is displayed when this can
be useful but especially useful if you
there is a company for example you want
a systematic way is from Tuesday to
application quality then it would
interesting for example in the process of
analysis of you have there you you
incorporate into all or some of these
tests they come up with 1 and 10
conveniently thought out
is finally and another important selection here
is the snake tep so you have a body
have a tablet xoom tablet it assumes
the body is a tablet application has
that follow the kms of the body but it has
some additional clinical silver types
of tablets né
It's so interesting to read
in the session to see if your app
he in fact following all that in the one
one of the important points that you will
see that is always is always very
emphasized is the adequacy of the
android design patterns so I
I always say that, I do not think so.
for whom then surely God is
getting annoying but followed the standards of
android design is very important and it
very important because when the user
i learned how to use android apps is
he is getting used to that pattern of
design then if you follow
design will be much easier
user use the app not so good
part of these this beginning is about you
follow the android design patterns
good part of them is easy to follow
example does not invent something
works hard is a crazy function
new beck button for example he too
it does very well the function of being a
beck button no then it's good not to put
another crazy feature another better
For example, do not change the
function of the home button unless
You really have a good reason to
do this is something else you use
all android components in general
how they should be used as
now take see them notifications other
important thing is to use
notifications so that notifications 10
It's fine, I think.
the revolt had a slight problem
technician was done as I was speaking
important to follow these egos lines to
number of applications to
terminals with application is already already
following those quality standards
It is not an important thing that he is
very well there is about permissions right
permissions are growing more and more
users are aware and permissions on the
There was a time when you want to
beginning of August mobile when the user
I had no idea that the caps mobile
they did not do much
attention permissions but more and more
both the user and us like google
we are not of importance each
once again the permissions model the
android as a fundamental mechanism
of security
so it's very important that you ask
user permissions only for
what really makes sense I see
many apps that ask for example
permission to send sms
except that ep is intended to
sending sms is very rare indeed one is
legitimate want to send sms always mission
of user
but then you can speak ah but this map
how is this I give a web option
to share is this ep through
sms or stay medium
But that's what makes you inner.
You do not need to ask the user for permission.
to send sms you can do it through
of the internet week however the system
will send that message through
the application values ​​of icms or
You do not have to send a week for
own account and for this you have to ask
self-permission
the important point that you will see
mentioned there and that many applications
sin is the audio issue in the audio in the
android app it should work
only when the application actually takes
screen and working unless the
purpose of your application is the
audioteca for example if you have a
music application that is playing
music while you're just doing other
things
then it is reasonable for you to play the
jingle ground
but for example it is a mistake if you have a
This game is not played after
user turns off the screen saves in his pocket
and keeps playing music is not any
user who has a musical taste
so it is a mistake if you are doing
This is something else that is a mistake
music keeps playing when the user
it's lockscreen so now it's over
connecting the phone is on the screen
music of your game returns the adriano still
is in the galaxy crimes also a mistake
now come back indeed poet is this was
automatically corrects for
you in the nude there bin because the order
given among the major was changed but
trusts in good practice whenever
determine if you actually own your quota
visible before you start playing the other
Another important point is the text calls
letterbox
Are you at the store buying a tablet?
that you are super happy with your new
nexus 7000 to run the application on it and
you suddenly see that the application
although not all have bought
these pixels are not
the mound pixels you bought
depending on the store you paid for
very expensive for these pixels in the then
you run your ep suddenly appears in the
little square that in the middle and
He appears in a tiny little square.
in the middle because the player spoke
tablet phone all the same then
I'm going to pick up a piece of the display
I will not use it to save time
programming
so this is an extremely
annoying user he wants to use the
whole screen then letterbox is what
happens when you try to cut
pieces of your display to make hair
ideally quality objective has to
occupy entire land whatever the
Screen size up to the largest you make
one thing that makes sense for screens
larger and therefore smaller is always a
thing that makes sense for smaller screens
but you cut a piece of paper never
It's right it's against something important and it's not
leave those services running after
of chantal in which to any erp
below a map again after I leave
for a period of one week
After a week I'll stay with him.
during the week is monitoring the
balance and petro and know from the
settings to determine if that
app is or is not a vampire of
drums
I hate battery vampire then by
more that the application is useful
this is one thing I have a colleague
my uncle is much older and he always talks
because, however much the goal is
useful
If he trains my battery, he's
making other apps useless
then every app gets trained
unreasonably battery users
mainly irritated
so this is the only other item
important not to let things count
you do not have to keep running
and use resources wisely
I remember you asking for GPS authorization
it's not a free thing
so even if the application depends on the
authorization to function properly
and you should make wise decisions with
about being closely monitored
every time then if you, for example, are a
restaurant search application and
You determined you called it an act.
infraction complain you finished at 5
minutes ago the user was in
Pine trees
then it is reasonable to assume that the sun
continue pine as the city comes
five minutes ago
you do not need to request dps data from
new being that it is 35 minutes hour
it was on the cheek
it is so the is always interesting
you make wise decisions about
resource saving
another important point is that they
speak is to restore the state in history
been an important thing because the
next when on android like you
know is the operating system that decides
kill or not an activity then when
operating system has passed
features low memory
he decides that the activity xyz good leave
I'll kill the good system.
physical activities, for example when the
user wants to go back to her
Restoration of activities but android
knows nothing about how many enemies
user already killed in your game then
Android will only restore its activity
now the activity content will remain
after its activity dies it is
responsibility
so you have to know that the user
already killed 3 enemies in that phase and
back to that state when
back the saints who active
if not you have that effect
bad that the user started playing his
game or use the apps came out of your
Puppy came back to Rome wrote
e-mail sms and seven years later resolved
back to your game and in that moment
he discovers that those three enemies
he killed and dedication time killing them
are back to life
and it was because of a blog was not for
cause of the difficult game then
that is, it is always important that you
restore the state properly
another point they mention too
important is good and construction science is not
application stabilities
strength 11 every time he does not have to have
a good swell from fifa app
choose from time to time yet he
it's not a very good app, right?
The ideal is to never give things to
when the user gives
so the ideal you see what matters is the
What is going on, I think this is
more or less what they were think is
appreciates the main novelty of
The latter means of and also with
related to the site the wrap the actor jorge
punctual with another interesting novelty
is that we have launched a platform
called buckley ice cream in some
election said he is nothing more than a
then it drops appreciably to the application that
it comes along with google play then
when you're using ft google
play on your android
it has an app cultured in it that
functions as essentially a
google service repository is
currently the service you have there is
the authentication service then you already
can summon the oppressor times in the
have chances are on the android blog
nokia android brings beautiful dots
both with you will notice that
there is the king who talks about the
goal scored and how to use the target with him
through google places you can
to authenticate the user
get a stump on a target for later
you could call others only from
Google
so it's cool because you're what
you make the user go through the
1 to 1 had a familiar path that he
is accustomed to authentication that
those standard screens of the law group then
per user a much better experience
What do you mean, your
interface for this then I
definitely this is if you do not
read the android developer's blog one
time it is worth to stop there and
see the news
That is what we are going to say here.
questions but before you start with the
questions asked by reader mode find
I want to give priority to who
is participating in renault live
here then that 21 questions to ask
live please
just talk tomorrow a lecture on
college about the standard spoke commented
the third round
I just want to know what happened.
some news about the tablet case
this ranking that is made it too
is done on tablets or however the
google tv
top-of-the-line
another and no one is perfect he is
agnostic regarding the device
globally the only thing I've ever had
you will only see the applications are
compatible with the tablet then the
ranking is the same only that it leaked
by the device
So what happens to you hours
certainly have all the staff that
was creating who he is compatible with
your device when you are viewing the
machine a device x it will not
show a y that is not compatible with
devices but the ranking is global or
be the relative ordering between items
and see if there is even though the exact list
be different depending on each
now to the status and
specifically also has had a
special category for tablets then
you have for example the fpx protagoras and
if you get into stf for tablets they are
essentially the applications that we
google we think are good examples of
tablet app but there is no
automatic filter for you to see by
example that time the application of
tablet né
even because it is difficult to define what is a
tablet indicative on why even good
part of mobile apps
works with boards
so it's very difficult for you to be
is difficult to tell if the application x
is a cell phone call
how much more then to explode
algorithm for automatic filtration né
so all those screens are really
ranking for the whole device but are
filtered for compatibility with your
sessions where this question yes yes that
same is to leave a question of one
right to make new mane is the
willian souza is here
good approach by inep to remove
ads to avoid keeping two
a version with the ad
others in advertisement
sometimes 12 and the two proteins are good
I particularly prefer the inep
cause the next you have one is always
You better have a listing on the goal alone.
because only if you have two listings you
It has two globe eps and reminds
respect your comments not
share one to the other then
user comments compliments or
epp I was this compliment will not be
shared automatically with one
paid blow then the users arriving
under pay he sees so you have only four
downloads and the only comment you have there
It's a guy who's complained a lot.
and then wait a little longer for you
then it is always recommended that you have
the minimum of lists possible to hear minimum
means a better case
so I definitely recommend doing
through grandson then you have one
application and through inep
I sold his grei to premium you come
to upgrade it to version is to train
a great advantage of this here you have
programming a functional logic for
determine whether or not the user buys the
version is to train but I think it's worth
feather despite the additional complication I
I think it's worth it because you
has a listing only then you get together
all your downloads will go
reflect the free version but the
kiss
unless its strategy of
marketing is based entirely on the
free version hence the page version
It means you're not so
interested in the pedro version while
example the ad revenue then
I need to be the main point of
strategies is just one of the two
Yes, as far as possible, I think it's
better have a minimum of messages
possible that this was important was
I need to pay you need this question for
that a county with the server to
developers I like to remember
is that if you have a tablet kite and the
mobile phones are separated by a
This play is usually an idea.
because precisely because the
user has certainly got much less
users who tried to follow users who
have cell phones
so if you did one is public there and
tablet users will download the version
of the tablet he sees that the business only has
known from 2030 downloads or 300
downloads is it starts to attack the
Application that good, you do not have much
people using when the lie, right?
you actually have users on the
version of the mobile phone, so it's always
cool you have a single version for
cell phone and treat them and means the
the android portuguese odivelas allows
do it the easy way you
put different neuro files and
put this different for tablets and
Cell phone so always better you
have a single version that works on
tablets and cell phone
The only exception I said to this
for example very specific games and
that use pdl a lot because
sometimes for example you have you have
device architectures using
example textures is compressed a
different format is then and then
sometimes it's worth you to apply
different so that the user does not have
which download a lot of bundle of data
who will not use it but out games a lot
specific and very heavy and I think
It's always worth your while to make a
only goal scoring is treated for peace
and also for the paid version
inversion is done I think I think this
would be my advice
brown that are worth all cases except
of sessions
ah good next question if it is someone has
a live question to ask and the
renault does not reflect the posture and
asking a comment question
Remember that I'm only reading the comments
of the post in android developers, I am
I do not see the comments on my
I hope I made my personal account
is to have a fifth nickel question that
there is already forecast arrival of unicef
in Brazil you recommend it's good
this question in two-part question
there is already a forecast of the arrival of r7 in
Brazil, I do not want you to have more
unfortunately does not have a forecast
you recommend the nexus the nexus seven
recommend nexus s certainly not
recommends nexus s do not think it is one of the
one of the more legal devices that
I already used and are not saying that.
Why good that even if they tell me
It's not like that because it's me.
personally the olive group outside the
google I use a lot in the other 17 is and I
I really like him because my father because
he has a good cost benefit he snow
not very concerned that he is
it's something else that I really like
fact that I have a certain size is the
problem that had conquered this 10
inches here they are very large
to download on a daily basis are they are
very difficult to use, that's how we are
they are heavy they sure are not leaving
some lighter the day but the tablets
The initial 10 inch was very
heavy
I liked it because it is very very
Practical in me the processor is very good
and anyway the only thing that is a little
bad and he only has a track on the
time command for things I do not
I can access for example from 3g with
he but that means that's part of grace
because his battery lasted much longer
for example the euro banknote in the
galaxy nexus is precisely because the radio
3g and consume much more battery than
What will you do and how will our time
galaxy nexus in the pocket in some cases
friend stone in new galaxy nexus no use
It's easy but then the answer is
definitely the president recommends
much the nexus 7 as tablet is is someone is
Thank you to do live on the coup
You commented now on the theme
applications he hangs on the wire
small screen that I have maybe then it is
this will demonstrate an application of
s
Are you going to show or not? I have more.
but I do not have any
application as I can demonstrate
no, I do not want to speak ill of any
application from any company on the
so it did not walk more than 15g of
find motives that do this right
but what to say
whenever you see an application that it
cuts pieces of your interface into the data
the recommendation is always going to google
in china much of seeing it to know that
Do you want to use all the fixed ones of your
tablet is that same floor is worth with other
with other things actually you in the
as a user he hates you too
the user anyone as users
android
we are very powerful creatures in the
our globe player comments is the
our king on the coup and that's one thing
that the developers they or I like
very much a team then in your
essential for us to see clearly in
application descriptions that start
with the carlos lock deal with three
batteries please do not have milk bad pro
my application
so either the user has a power
very great all this and it is always legal
the eyes of course use this for the
well to use this to encourage
players to make high application
quality as a developer
of course you have to always give
ears to users and do not let
angry because they have this weapon
quite powerful in their hand that thinks
much in the group and obviously it's not like
says the expression we are going now to the
next question that dodô moderator who
the following is from daniel de goiânia who
the spam
if I make an ep that works
exclusively or to give tips for the
bep game and if you put the name of the actor
for brad pit stops or tips for
bergson, this is considered to be
good
let's just take a general look at the
What do you want me to like you?
What today for the next is when you
places on the streets in the description of the
application on the mount of the bus that
just to make the app appear in
unrelated searches
then there are those applications that are
desperate and that for example the title
the application is called for example the
game x aa and in the title itself called
best do not know how much you like and ride the
game the application title is 20% title
and 80% random superlatives
this is expected because the
application is wanting artificially
to appear naked in the site's ranking is another
thing in the application description he
stay put terms warm brazil
original for example fan fest is not cold
amazed encapsulated here to try
make the arrangement of the coup and finds
that those terms are relevant poet
it's then we continually take the air
we suspend applications that do today
I hope that today you take something that is
extremely bad
we do not like iran the user does not
likes who likes it is now something else
which is especially expected is
you try to make you try to cheat the
user
he thinks that just because the rain is a
something that he is not right
and in the case, for example, it is called an ep of
Portuguese project means I
particularly I think if not here
we like it because when the user
look for bdp he says
and was a reasonable search result in the
Own a prayer, Mrs.
looking for the bb is reasonably
reasonable to assume that it may have
interested in an ep called ric upp
I will not discuss whether it's cool or not
make an ep and quote
I will not say no, I will not go in
merit jack white right because it is not
mine does not know but assuming you
be allowed to do this on time
somehow I wanted I did not
I will consider this as what it is today.
because I do not wonder why when the
user search pp this is reasonable that
he wants to find the overweight also the
that it is unreasonable for example a
application of a game this I already saw
very very very much i will not cite examples
but I've seen many games that are
related are games about to shoot
things in other things and the game-training
suddenly in the description of him britney
Spears Lady Gaga Do not Know 404 Unless
that what to say
and is the lady gaga britney spears are
somehow the game is that I
I hope you are.
maliciously try to get you a
ranking position searches that are not
related but particularly you a
app that objective course gives tips
pro b pigs
He calls himself pt pt, I think he is.
Great to be wrong and call yourself tips for
beto what are tips to see pigs is topic
fame I do not know how many and how many
best downloads is final
is this here wortmann but sir
called that the research projects
I do not see any problem
is someone who is a question that does the
river and we will not go to the next
android near the voter is Gustavo
oak budapest hungary
the fallible method prom is costly
would be a reference to a few way
sometimes there are problems in using the
where you want a variable the
field in the class had
called saw Fábio bahia only once
The Fawha Bahia and it is not no it is not
particularly expensive but if you go
often use a very closed loop
huh
brazil often generates a null that
will take up to five times per second
not worth calling all the time because
is a cost called function is always a
I do not like it
so what to say also the recommendation
It's if you talk a few times and you do not
like her in an intensive way can be
called to live life when you
want to
now if you are a loop and need
of high performance you will have to
keep thinking about it all the time
for this it is worth not only to level there but
want to compete for
any kind of method call
called method is expensive it is cheap to
do it from time to time but the face you
will upgrade with five times and
needs and needs to be fast
in this case I would recommend you record the
movie is the personally what to say my
programming method is to make a movie
for that thing is not because it was level
baby be slow but because you can stay
cleaner to hear from you because every time
It's called riverbed you need.
Evolve the code to test the
practice in the face of seeing bdr
power lower then you can
cause all those relatives and make a
test to button the beam to a
variable
so I think it's much more elegant
the code becomes more readable when you are
I'm writing to emi ok, it does not put any
thing because you put the whole
expression is not johnny the prom but this
It's my personal style of guessing
that each one has its own style but
in terms of performance and I would only be
worried if you're calling the
dance a million kisses but other than that
I think it does not have any problem then
Let's go to the next question, someone here.
too crazy to do the clean in the
renault
do not let her take advantage
to present the net marin grandson
universe navy then the navy grandson
is my colleague reveals problems to him
For those who do not know, I'm
moving to the United States or going
change the United States in the fifth
next week
So I'll go to work and
keeps seen with android damage or thirst
google then who will continue with the
relationship with developers is
Honest ladybug, that's good. Let's go.
next question I'll pass on the
goal taken in having is how long you
was inspired to ask a question to the
I live the next question that the ship
I had flamenco flag google maps api
the opinions of flamengo quis bes survs
application developer in the
philippines is to bring Portuguese, whether it be me
Can I get my data from google?
maps and piauí to use in the service of
location to issues involving good
The answer to this is actually complicated.
but if it were to be summed up in one word it is
dependent and the terms of service of the
they are extensive, I am not
Specialist in this because I do not work
in the garbage team in pine forests
then but only with this information
that carry on the question is very
difficult to know if this use qualified
he is in or not one of the heroes in the
so that's how I recommend you read
the terms of service of the
sap and find out if its use is in
or not, but they know of trials here
This is more than it gives to decide
Well, someone has a question to ask.
live or leaving aside the
comments from you is Bruno is
I respect about after I've seen where
come over
he had that system of updating the
application updates a different part
as I had before analyzing
I only saw it once recently in
followed after I arrived I saw a game
that preview this but I have not seen more is of
difficulty in programming this
method is the goal came out only a
code moved week application it
makes the comparison but even so what
they could say about whether there is that
partial updates actually
incremental updates was one thing
that we launched is working on the
google what happens the update
incremental it should update the
parts of pkk that are needed to
reduce the traffic you need
to bring a peta is often this
it is possible is often not possible
on the developers side the
developer does not do anything
This is not authorizing if this
it's not happening, it's not any fault
the developer's fault is entirely
Wow, but nowhere to people.
really want to ensure that
update will be made
incrementally in software than what
may or may not happen depending on the
depending on the application of the
specific circumstance is and this comes
happening with my apps or not
I know it's not guaranteed that it will
happen with all applications is not
and I think it depends a lot for example
of the pkk framework that I apply for
we're a little something here -
There is no way to make a pet
something this thing is not
minimally compatible then depending on
of the update the government made to
Sometimes we can not send a pet.
incremental is depending on the result of the
update, we can do it on
instrumental part and in this case it is
implemented so but I do not have
sure why this is not not
working to say more often
but promised you do not need attention and
prevention is not but it is not something that
is so big the morning the developer
disagree
What makes you automatic, I have the suit.
should automatically do this then
if he is not doing it or because
I happen to be the ones you are applying for.
using are not allowed for example
savior by having something that makes
incompatible with this or because the group
is broken in some way that the
people do not know this way anyway
it's not the developer's fault
did not come back yesterday to any blog
personal happen this happens too
with those expansion files in the
in short a relevant commentary and a
common mistake that I see that some
second apps is the following they use the
that the way of expansion of applying and
after he uses it he decides to pick up and
delete the file was not now already
I will try to expand because it is
I need more
This is a mistake because the togo that goes
think the following my god disappeared disappeared
there is a provision to apply
I think I'm going to download again then
they are trapped in a cycle of
stay down fat exp.
because the application very smart
resolved to delete or after it is finished
then definitely use the
advice is do not mess with the quote you
and he does not have to write and
try to mean do not try to stay
Deleted it we did not determine the question
I do not think I have doubt in
relation to the law of the end at night starting
the play doh's play of being law
put an effective big excuse this
language that can be differentiated in the
appeal claimed I am is a good future
recognizes that anything that people
receives routinely because it does much
sense helm already has a way of you
find apps app
nothing more natural than you can
also locate fpf football up to
because when you have a time it is
highlighted worldwide
it would be interesting the highlight graphic
appearing in the user's own language
currently we do not have it or
fmf football is
equal for all countries one of the
reasons why this was not
prioritized so far is because it is that
the filet that you want it to be is a brief and
it has to be much more serious because
text
if you have software that has a
paragraph of the text explained in ep alice
cooper is because it has to have a paragraph
explaining that ipea is probably in the
clue that is making reservation is not that
will be very successful then the idea of
fit strike that he explains
graphically that it does and finally
on the back in a sentence until the
time itself to the very application of the
gmail has reached exactly
So this is definitely a
pitbull is the highlight of the model is the
The following is how differential
configuration for devices
different through gmail is this is a
very fat question william is because it is
one thing that is is very easy to do
but sometimes very obvious then the
problem is the following but it is not
very sure for the mayor also wants
say those like the cannons in it then
apple ids that is is that control that
appears on the user's home screen that is
a way for the user to put
relevant information from the
application has for example has
that the egypt g mail that lets you see
your screen mails on the home screen
before you open you have a video by
example of weather forecast has many
things have in my opinion
are underutilized, you do not have a
huge market for minor minor egypt
and smaller and does not have enough areas
that is, users stay in the
sometimes because they need to go
look very interesting to think
on the device
they do not find so tip has a
Huge market users wanting to download
widgets widsets is sometimes for
certain categories
Now his question is very relevant.
we did not even all its should be
behaved exactly the same way
no tablet on the phone for example
should have a
different from the course by phone
if you just of course or ide on android
manifesto it always has the same layout
which is not desirable
if you want to declare layouts
different you have to do has
what to do with what's called the dem
resources nébula de mujerão percent
or false
It is the second resort you will declare
within a x ml that is called
good example xml and old have succeeded
anyway it's a right value then you
declares it as goalkeeper value the type
to buller it as it is
declaring a file is ml points you
can put it according to what
you want in any folder in the
within the sub-month is you place
it in for example receive the traits
something is not going to show any
thing is a configuration qualifier
that it is extremely important to attribute abortion
whether by that resource
depending on the version of the android then
summarizing summarizing who arrived here
Do you have a resort you could call
example let's suppose you're just
Wishing you compliments noticed then you
has an abundant resource is called
establish a resource that should be
the water that is made to notice says that
is doing in the old English
the traits x large you will put there the
its bueno ml points and inside it you
defines the so-called stable with the
southern value
then you will create another xml file
within the directory rescue old
trace anything else for example the
phones or I am old in the
practice being able to buy everything else
inside it is created a file with the
same name and you put a resort with the
same name whose value is false
this will make that feature
woman has no true tablets value and has
a value falls when you find
thing when you set the first
music for example x large else is
When will you set your idiot in the
your android manifests that you do it
has a parameter that android 2.1 nor
good points and I will not even see
can receive trophies and hardcore or he
can be a reference to what the
Boolean resource a powerful and it is in this
point where you will point your resort
you have just set the
which can be either false depending on that
Are you ready to play?
then you do not enter two
egypt sides android sea one
settings has android 2.0 or
equal to a resort bug is light and
another has black dots andré
pointing to denial
according to the treasure then you for example
tablet enamel does not know to point to
denial of that first is unfortunately
I'm not afraid it sums up smart for
connecting a leonine resource is
I set it right below the south define
one that is false but not easy
to do then it's pretty easy of all this but
not entirely obvious at first then
I think that's a good question and it's
super important make this concern
you to hedge and that is
appropriate by screen size of the
User's device is super
mainly important because
ovaries and want the isi to have said it
be optimized for non-brunet screens
It hurts but then you're going to have 22
21 unifest xml to do because
I was sick and another to hit
Enamels tablet my spoke to him
with the chosen one is different from the channel
So when are you grounded?
idea when trying to enter the
xml that defines what trophy is the
that will be read and when you are
running a thing that is not a tablet is
the xml that defines how the sun will be
free
you do this by putting them
appropriately the older folders
through this will be the correct xml was
selected is that the exam is to define the
stable dish or depending on the user
mounted and on your other brands you
defines it to point out that feature is
take a look at my talk from the
google wael that in our room that was mine
hard was dick we talked about how
make and bring up the user who are
compatible with previous versions of the
android
one of the tricks we recommend
just use busdoors to do is
that are different depending on the
that you if you are for example we
Sincerely, I do not like comics.
same technique can be applied to
not only differentiate this year by
bin
as the difference also for example
stage of cell phone or any other
setting you want
Can you think that way?
that is to say any differentiation that
you can do through the exorcist
Can you do it through this?
technique are definitely not
technical
during the day in your pocket for
these cases
is someone else a question here live
in the recall are doubts and that is now
to travel but if I continue to do
use of drugs in Brazil always has the
principle yes
The only difference is that I'm going
transmit through our studio and
kept the ninth but the time will be
fixed in Brazil where there is no time
It's really convenient for two
You actually share because it's going to be for me.
the winner does not mean that I can
make legal from within normal hours
at the same time
automatically for a bonus is
provided by the rotation of the
planet
He ends up falling at the right time.
Brazil also ends up falling more than
pleasure night
so I'm sure the position
geography of its roots in Brazil was
when it was quoted carefully
designed to make this possible.
thank you to the team that
designed the test is then someone has a
ask me to do the same
I'll leave one more question of one
then I do not think it ended up in the
last question just comment
Inter has already done online with
play make a biographical film country ne
So I guess we broke up now.
questions 18 so now we
arrives at that tense moment of the night in
What do you or do you ask or start?
Then sing the ball asking questions.
You do not want to wrap up the years.
products did represent themselves above the
standard on the Brazilian team rather than
will bring more these news
I'll keep bringing what is
doing galt sam
at the beginning with the same format as
I was doing until today with news
What's the legal point of editing it there?
a kennel that is easier to invite 10
pixels to appear and repeated in the regal
kind of interview is right but I do not
I know very well how it's going to be
day to day side of the rebels but in
As far as possible I will always try
bring interesting things to each
regatta we were thinking
Any good any more questions?
Ok, leave it and if anyone has any more
ask here to do in the post of the para
the tax program takes to
click here
Okay, so one more question, so I guess
I'm going to ask a question just for
to avoid that I have to sing my song
next question is this thing that
is that we build at the beginning of the
regal chance of this and quality checklist
of applications asks him if he
also applies to games or is only a
checklist applications you have a
difference between games and applications
in this case is good the last question ah ah
ah ah the answer to the question
next games applications they are
essentially different snows are in
general rules for applications do not
applied much more to applications
even games and keeping the rule separate
but we do not have a specific section
for games on that one is that one
list, but he always recommends that
games follow more or less great light
applications as long as you want
nothing basic is to have good sense in this you
have solved the game has hundreds of one
list that make no sense
so you can see in the game for example
follow the online costs of interface
android is more or less né mother e
also necessary because the purpose of the
user when he plays a game is
emergence a new experience to be
energy in the experience that joe is is not
I mean, he does not have as much
goal of having a productivity
something is, so if you
it's making game you do not need
follow that online market sometimes
very rigid then always
important
I mean follow that big loot
lines with some common sense for you
can make a game do not follow
literally for example imagine the
excellent until there's something
things that are anti patterns for games
huh
I've seen many games that are very
interesting but suddenly you arrive
at the end of the phase and you receive the
android standard alubox said congratulations
you went through phase
because when you left when I see that
default android nokia dialog he
You're not saying that the standard is ugly.
but when you receive the default
android on the chip midway and that breaks
experience of the game of the immediate
thinks that something very wrong in the
game is not the contest eg it's you
passed the stage defeated the boss but I
I could not record your status because
He gave
I always thought something very
when I see a little of those in the
then it is always recommended to do with
that visual interface of the game she
well integrated with the game above
do not do a thing that surprises
user suddenly appears a pope having
based on the android style question
The same thing applies to
pulp is the standard of android
although it is very easy to create it
should only be used for those warnings
which are crucial things for the user
something very wrong for example
has to save your file from an error in
time to save technology the most
is a network error and I tried to back up
but it is a backup and is reputed to be the
another is soon by remembrance then
all this dialogue, for example, the error
when you were trying to repair the
error lobby
in this case the dialogue but if it is not
a critical thing of this kind is always
walk you integrate it with visual of
your app same thing for example
When the story tried to send, I tried
record an appointment in the calendar and not
I was able to record because the time zone
wrong can not be something i'm doing
This is not to show up in red.
something that does not have clothes so much
user when a goal appeared on the
screen you give a part of the novel
It's practically a scary thing.
in the annex would lead to practically
a slap in the face of do
critical thing
This review Congratulations, you can
do it right then the user gets a little
bewildered with this is the same thing
as for example I have seen for example
that those neighborhoods progress in
area of ​​that progress bar but the
android pattern and lets use a bar
specific game and always gives the
impression that there is something like that
a lot of you want to download the game
so you suddenly come back to the
system standard is good but have a
Brazil question has a lot of difference
between everything I can record a
their abpi television is the same as the
zero point and a different radio one
very different athlete has a lot of
difficulty one thing it is the same
standard only has to care per cent
television difference from that other
essentially the same lane on the left
for android it is not certain that neither
android version you hold national
it's an android you want a great
This is what is on a table, but it is the
I think the fundamental problem is that
he is not going to google tv is not on
however the technician tatá and we is not that
be harder at nothing
I think that the fundamental problem that
players have to solve google tv is
know what the user interested in
google tv
certainly not the one for example an ep
which is very successful on the cell phone
it may not be so successful in
Globe TV because there is no interest
users there because you have to imagine
the case of easy use imagine how many
hours using google tv
He is sitting on the couch he is away.
of the device
then your device depends a lot on the
interaction with the user and maybe
suddenly this main user image
use for example does not have touchscreen
user can not get there with a finger
screen and interact with the application
So this already kills a lot of people.
applications that depend on the corner to
do that
I remember that the user will have that
flight control had to enter since
and application is always very important
that the application makes sense in this
context you imagine the user when
he is using the google tv app
he is more interested in consuming
content of what interacts is
interested in interacting only when
that's going to hit the
content so he wants it for example
youtube is a good example of the application
works fine for google tv for wanting
the user interacts just to see the
next video and then will consume
quite content the same thing against
the electrons because they show videos and
about 60 do not remember the user what
he is interested in doing is being
lazy is there on the couch to consume
content and is not so interested
enter paragraph text paragraphs and
no not so interested present
in apps that take a lot of interaction
to do something interesting is
so I think the fundamental challenge
How did you get on the technical side for the challenge?
fundamental is not knowing how to write the
fundamental challenge is to have
this vision of what to write for a drop
it the market for google tv it is
growing much more then according to
and inflation in the new countries will
appearing opportunities are appearing
new goes to new apps is to do
quite successful
then definitely recommended for
everyone who does not, who is not
start doing it still take a look
on the mastercard and start thinking about
first not so much on how to do
shadow google tv
think if it makes sense your ep works
google tv itself does not make sense to think
in what other variant of the south would
You suddenly have a school.
which works great for mobile and
depends on interaction and suddenly has
another version of it that is really cool
design or TV that does not exist
creation to the scene then lose everything
adapting the use case to the
However, adapting a question of adapting the
code on this tip google tv itself
One more question in New York is when
puts a google player app
directly available for the whole
planet I can imitate the countries or
depending on the language I have
I automatically get it to restrict
some countries have something of a law of
country that does not accept an app
what happens then when you publish
google app is by default not
I know that you specifically restricted
it will be available to all
planets in the universe where it is
able
at the moment the applicant in the universe where
It works the planet earth people are
trying to believe in our planet
moments but inside the planet earth he
it works by default it goes
operate in all countries that can
be a player
if you make no choice
find I just want to be available
for all countries
now different countries have different
laws depending on the type of
application it can be locked in
some countries, right?
There are countries, for example, where
extremely are controllers about
g game app and gaming games
bit right
there are a lot of good games but there are countries
which control for example the application
that are of deck except it is any
anything that might suggest gambling
then it is in these cases that the
its application-side only not looking like a
certain country is not by some filter
buckley
but that's what I said.
it was you who did not want to specify which
are the countries where you will block
over active or not
and recalls that it is entirely
Developer's responsibility to know
in which countries it can launch a
application on the other and does not
monitoring applications that are
sent auto-tracking
to determine for example if you
tries to send a small porch or
Do you intend to
a small one that has some form of
abuse of Google's terms of service is
but we are not an authority to
say what you can and can not do
in each country, right?
so if you make an ep that plays in a
country is the responsibility of the
developer is to know what the laws are
of each country what you can do or
no we do not do a previous review
in editorial and applications
so it's always important to be aware of
these legal matters, we do not
we are no tax authority in the
responsibility is always the responsibility of the
developer collect taxes
properly then we do not have
no authority in this area
This is interesting because it gives a lot of
freedom on the other hand has
developer has enough and has to
use this fairly responsibly
It's one more question about
advertising is as in the case where I
I bought the app the go go won
something about it forced to use but the
I can create a mechanism
advertising and not use the property where
What do we mean, do not you remember?
who was at the service of the goal but
as far as I know if you can have many
apps that use other
public announcements in the new then
I think there's no restriction on you.
can make your own solution
advertising you can invent your
own solution
I particularly already mean not me.
I am not an authority in this is not just because
I'm talking here but I give one
serious look at the google service
play but so far as I can remember it is
My memory is not very good, I do not
I remember that we went and today but how far
lembro does not have any restriction on goal
play about it
It is then, but I would respond.
about advertising is interesting
not only about advertising, it reminds
something stronger than this is the
there is not a
to play or not play then there is a lot
people who think government is a
monopoly then if you use android you
have to use the other one is lie
copley it you can publish a map
google play and you prefer free
to publish one and any other
market or even a web stream without
no market at all can much
Well you'll meet on the web and leave now.
download a sinner such hebe you want
do this you do not like the gol players
did not need the suit even has a
thing that is fundamental and to differentiate
which is what the terms of service of the
google play and what you can or can not
to do with android what you can or not
to do with android is to that limit, right?
because it is a relationship between you and
Not only is our user limited by our
relationship or you but what you
can make a goal is a little more
for example is to have a series of
a category of ethics that can not
enter the goal plate for example to apps
as with explicit sex content
It's certain that you can not get into the goal, that's it.
does not mean that you can not do the
android is not only means it can not
publish a book of this type new player
but nothing prevents you from for example from
follow a trend directly through
the same thing with use by
make apps that are apps that are
other markets you can not publish
in google play, it's me, for example.
I can publish the ep and call bruno play
inside the goal board you want is
decide that he does not like the goal and I want to
make a new store called by a
player
and I can not put the bruno play
inside the goal is but I can publish the
group on a play through the web by
example
then you can not make a goal and
you can do from the web is really
important as was the case of creating 11
no play
but anyway you have to enable
the android they receive apply in sta no
how google play accepts the
applications that scroll down and
automatically was already released
is the user has to have to put the
crytek box from receiving assets from
other sources, right?
and yes it's true because if I enter
I directly focused on modifying where I
I have access to this part of wanting
unrestricted use of a source code
even this is taught us to respect the
android source code because it is a
source code does not win on your machine is
You can do whatever you want with it, right?
so there is no restriction of this
type when you can occur within the
license terms you can do what
you want
including android source code
modify freely on it was in the
your device you can modify
freely distribute the devices
you can freely modify and
manufacturing devices including various
manufacturers make neither a manufacturer
You must have google permission to
use android source code
the manufacturer needs to knock on the door and
said so I can use the product
android year everyone automatically
can use the code was to change
so this is one of the great advantages
of android on what's different from saying
You're free to do this to your
device is because there are
devices where you can replace the
there are devices where you can
you can not, that means it's a
thing that depends on the factory
agents do not have seven
manufacturers that allow
other than most do not
but if you buy for example google
spirit of peace with the galaxy nexus you
You can do this, you can not
It's very easy to give it a
that what you want in him it's done
to make it the effect you can
do this kind of thing
Then you can download to finish I go
just barely reached the area in
which you can download to the strong loop
you can install on your own device
can you make a website book me
wanted a version of android is very
best of the original contract and the eyes
can pick up and install kilos and
sixty-one inscription with it only that
The only thing we have one
certification process to ensure
that the abuses that we
we got the droid brand
they are compatible with a series of
tests to avoid having you there
android device that does not
are compatible with anything
to maintain this compatibility is
working fine I just give the name
from android to those devices that
function fashion compatible so
compatible with what we expect more
means that if these mean if the
device you did not work
when in this way you can call
something else and did not understand the
just can not say it's not time for the
official android device
so I saw on the river a while until already
about how the update medium worked
of operators
victims is a type of democracy that
source code came to the manufacturer
manufacturer to make a modification and
operator
I loved doing this change after
google having to release for later power
having a cult has something more complex
said is a very high cost or what the
what can you say about why
of this delay even taxi x
Brazil has not yet been used
I have nexus united states that he
soon reorganized many people report
x even though a nexus was not
updated on the galaxy it's not quite a
galaxy odor is administered by
samsung in Brazil, right?
it does not automatically receive the
first goal and I definitely do not
I do not recommend
ah I do not recommend plugging it
bild of him
I mean why do you ask the question
your guarantee but if you are, if you want to
you be brave you can take
do it right
You can pick it up and give it a go.
boot or e on the bike and battión install there
It's very easy to do this, why do
with the direction of the event the actor jeremy
binnie are available you can still
download download on the net the public today
officially
You can lower the tone of the galaxy.
nexus project because he bin and I'm me
I recently did this xis here
in Brazil it worked very well now it's
recommended does not recommend
because it makes you miss
guarantees but the period of
for example I do not see why in the
urn but he's answering your question
original is why why is it so difficult
update therefore no update is
something that depends
that is to say, it depends on the
manufacturer or operator because at the end
it is they who are responsible to the
consumer to support that
I can tell if you think I'm a
operator, so I'm responsible.
to users because that
phone I asked him to work and
if I upgrade if and directly to
google fort immediately
without much testing is betrayal and
example to finish my support team
to support these cases and it would be
or not be irresponsible on my part
what power could have for example a
android modification that works
very well certain devices but in this
device that I was selling
last year
it might not break I do not do it
update and suddenly you just can not
make calls
then it is a very responsibility
large number that the operating
keep your devices running
on the other hand obviously does not have a
capitalism in which the interest of the
of manufacturers is to see devices in the
so naturally they will prefer the
times you buy if it were a new one
but sometimes it is not so capitalist
because the following is the
personal cell technologies
fast development a lot that
I've seen complaints about why it manufactures
x does not update the device and it is because
sometimes does not give children health and
can handle a more
recent
today because if you put cell phone and
much Spanish sweat to the air force
of the type of put and realizes that
it rotates half the speed it gives
another version
so mobile devices are things
extremely complicated you write the
Driver 17 is a really slow thing and
expensive
so I mean I've never worked in a
operator or manufacturers to know
exactly what it costs but I already
I have worked with engineering of
software and I have already worked writing
driver is inclusive I know it is
extremely complicated you make a
driver for an embedded device
so you especially keep the
things updated when things like that
change is necessary to make a version
new android has a full suit
with experience and do not even decide that
will map different memory and
Suddenly my panties broke so it is
reasonably complicated you make a
Existing device update is well
complicated is then a series of factors
who join him
he really does what we have
as ideal for the android system what
understood the world with the Android system
This is not so important.
the fact that the manufacturer does not
android should not be so with the sky
that the ecosystem and the
face west gives all the tools
for developers to 0 are
compatible with multiple platforms
because it's a lie if I
said not one day all Brazil will
be the same, everyone will have the
latest version of android takes me people
in my opinion this is not going to happen
because this will only happen if people
had very strict control of the
droid is something that is not in the
ours do not speak our philosophy today
On day our philosophy I asked of
diversity is a philosophy
manufacturers may they should have this
freedom to put the version of android
they want the devices according to
what makes the most sense for them and
by users
then it adversity you will be
always in the heart of android will be
Difficult you have a hard time imagining
android ecosystem without this diversity
platform and the ecosystem and the
sk is all are prepared for this
they are made for it so I do not
I think this is a very negative thing.
on the contrary, I have this diversity
freedom is a very very thing
positive android differentiating it
before other platforms I think
this explains in large part the success of the
android on the market out there is not for
That's what we have over a thousand
android devices on the market
I think it's much more than what
many other platforms and in case of
a scenario of being a top of the line is
new update is because there were still
time producing android testing is
now he launches the new one in my time
still if the explanation can happen
this is because it is because the android is
all very fast then for example
just left because can win leaves
I'm still in the middle of the phrase to speak
Look, it'll just roll right back to
me then is the person the other actions
happen so fast then if you are
a manufacturer probably if you are
if you have for example if you pass a
year them a positive return
sometimes it's hard for you to keep
conversion and sometimes have problems
For example, the system has a
specific technical reason why the
garden does not work our goal x
so I'll try to cross the avenue
break because no one else does something x
with memory here does not work with
my abduction plaque
It happens then, but it means
background is the freedom for the
and for the manufacturer to do so is
for example your users
that is, user has the freedom to
buy other positives and for him it is
much is crucially important to have
gerb even so he will look for another
manufacturer another operator in our
part of the freedom of the market and
user can choose whatever they want
the manufacturers he has to respect
that's because nobody but nobody
would buy their devices and
respect for example in the case of
apple releases developers a beta
month or so, as well as the
android does not use family it already with
he shows when he is already doing
an event that shows the new android already
shows the final version already analyzes already
releases the source code is there is a good
watch a beta that gets first
google professionals with a limited
and sim developers fine
good to good obviously we make goals
internal
so our people have access
things as they are developing
but we do not have a public program
It's not supposed to do that so we do not
has a public initiative to do
for example air let's make a beta
open for developers
I think this is a suggestion
good evening and I think a lot of people already
they did it but for now we do not
has a forecast to make a program
themselves because even so what the
people want
we suddenly made a program
of these is that it would stop self
encourages you to do things that are
compatible with
ideally in the ideal world when it launched
When did you launch jelly bean?
application 2 15 years should break
none in the ideal world our side in
all those who were 23 years old
working continue and it's just not
true if any developer
players are using something
that they should not for example map and
private
I see a lot of application that uses skin
Private for example picks only private
rather than public pirates
and then released a new version of android
mg by breaking because they change did
private partnerships
then in that case telling her what
it means who is wrong in this case
he is a player who only uses private
but in the ideal world, I do not want to
public beta because it should be
really compatible
This is something we always have to do.
a public beta to look for and if these
repetitive things could be the pressure
during even doing things that are
100% backwards compatible
in summary, there is no plan
current spirit of making certain
but the suggestion is not very
interesting I would particularly like
to see it happen
Good, we think it ended on time.
right here
so it's good for whoever it was
with questions I would like to ask in
today will make this new way here
in two weeks
questions through the decree that will
post a link soon
It's good, thank you, everyone who watched it.
It's nice, I'm glad to talk to you.
and see you in two weeks
the next rival and promises to return another
instead of directly serving good
Thank you all and mistake